hello everyone and welcome to Paul
morphy's famous a night at the Opera
Ponte E4 Ponte E5 Knight F3 D6 and D4
challenging the villagers defense Bishop
to G4 already a weak move because now
after Queen captures and D captures
Bishop to C4 threatens Checkmate so
Knight to F6 now Queen B3 with a double
attack here with Queen to E7 and Knight
to C3 as morphy was an artist not a
butcher Bishop to G5 B5 allowing morphe
this beautiful sacrifice captures
captures and captures with check 97 the
castles now again attacking the Knight
here Rook to Da defending and now the
spectacular Rook captures on these seven
Rook captures and Rook to D1 forcing
black to unpin here so now the Knight
can move but it doesn't help the bishop
captures on D7 with check Knight
captures and now morphy finishes it off
with a spectacular Queen sacrifice Queen
to B8 check Knight captures and The Rook
38 is Checkmate that's it that's
Murphy's Knight at the Opera hope you
enjoyed it